So we're going to define a special
kind of operator called a contraction
mapping, and we're going to say
an operator's a contraction mapping
if it has this property.
So B is some operator, and it's mapping
value functions to value functions.
If it's the case that for all value
functions, so all value functions F and
G, and some multiplicative factor
gamma which is less than 1.
If it's the case that the distance
between B applied to F and
B applied to G has to be smaller than or
equal to gamma times the original
distance between F and G, then we
say that B is a contraction mapping.
It's causing things to get closer
together, tighter together.
So this notation here is sometimes
called the infinity norm, the max norm,
and all it's doing is saying,
this is a function of states and
actions, so which is the largest?
What's the largest state action
pair in terms of absolute value?
>> Okay, so that's just saying,
what's the maximum value that
the function Q can have?
>> Or that it currently has,
yeah that's right.
So when we write F- G max
norm really what it's saying,
what's the biggest difference
in Q values between F and G?
And this is corresponding Q values.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So F- G is saying what's the biggest
difference between these two Q
functions at any state action pair?
Whatever that largest difference is,
we're going to multiply it by
something that makes it even smaller.
And we're going to say that, for
it to be a contraction mapping,
is has to be the case that,
if you apply that mapping to F and you
apply that mapping to G, the distance
between the resulting functions is even
closer together than they started.
>> And
that makes it a contraction map, okay.
>> Yeah this is how we're going to
define contraction mapping, and
this is going to give us all sorts of
nice properties, and it's also going to
happen a lot in the kinds of operators
we get in reinforcement learning.
>> So
just to make sure I have this right,
since the infinity norm
finds the biggest value and
here you define the difference between
two functions, at least the infinity
difference between two functions, being
wherever their greatest distance is.
It's certainly the case that over time
as we apply this operator over and
over again, the point where their
maximum is, the state action pair where
their maximum is,
might change every time, right?
>> Right.
That's right.
So this max norm is computing for
the specific
value function that it's given where
the biggest absolute value is.
And that could be different on
this side of the equation from
this side of the equation.
There is no reason that it needs to
be the same over and over again.
And in fact when we're using B
to be a value iteration operator
it does tend to move around a lot.
>> Okay.
So you would expect it
to move around a bit,
at least as you're going
through value space.
>> Yeah, exactly.
However, let's not worry
about that quite yet,
let's actually do some
contraction mapping examples on
just scalar values where it's
really easy to reason about them.
>> Okay,
yeah I think that would be cool.